>> So, hello, everyone. Thank you all for
coming out. We are very happy to have Justin
Fox here today in the office to talk about
his new book, "The Myth of the Rational Market."
This is Justin's first book, but he has been
a blogger and contributor to the Times Magazine
blog for--since 2007. And before that, he
worked for Fortune Magazine for over a decade.
So we are very excited to have him here in
the office today. So, everyone, please welcome,
Justin Fox.
>> FOX: And it looks like I'm going to have
to stay close to this mic, so I'll like lean
on the podium. I don't know. I thought what
I should do is start with a story that goes
back to my--when I was first starting out
at Fortune Magazine. It kind of explains why
I ended up writing this book and why I think
it matters. And, luckily, a financial crisis
happened to make lots of other people think
it matters, too, but I was writing this book
long before that came along. What is was is
I just got in to Fortune. I haven't been a
business journalist before. I'd just been
sort of a general interest business writer.
But somehow, I ended up covering the intersection
between corporations and financial markets,
corporations in Wall Street. And one of the
first big stories I wrote for the magazine
was about the whole weird practice of managing
earnings and managing Wall Street's consensus
earnings forecast and trying to beat the consensus
by a penny. And this whole dance that developed
early in the early to mid '90s and, I mean,
actually, the founders of this company made
a really big deal about not wanting to participate
in that dance, but that was later. So this
was 1997, and it was very clear that there
were huge amounts of effort at the CFO levels,
CEO level put into making sure that you beat
the consensus earning target of all the Wall
Street analysts by at least a penny or two.
And as I was--so I documented this talk people
about why they did it, and I thought it would
be interesting to look at the academic literature
on this whole phenomena. And it turned out
there were lots of papers by accounting professors
explaining that, yes, there was lots of evidence
that companies did weird things in order to
make their quarterly earnings, first of all,
come out smoothly rising over time, but, second
of all, to meet these consensus targets. But
then there was this really weird thing about
all of this accounting literature is when
they went around to try to explain why, they
came up with kind of weird things like maybe
it had something to do with their bonus structure
or maybe it was some debt covenant, but they
basically weren't allowed to talk about the
sort of most obvious reason why all the CEOs
thought they were managing their earnings,
which was to affect their stock price. And
the reason for that was because if you were--had
a Ph.D. and got a Ph.D. in accounting in the
last 25, 30 years, you were taught--because
accounting is sort of this--taught as the
subset of academic finance--you were taught
that you couldn't fool the market, that as
a corporate executive, you couldn't--I mean,
unless you were out right lying, but if you're
using relatively transparent things like just
shoving earnings into one quarter instead
of the next, that people can see through.
But that should actually have absolutely no
impact on stock price and, therefore, that
can't be why anybody was doing it. And I remember
that struck me as a little strange of the
time. I ended up writing the article just
saying, well, maybe all these CEOs and CFOs
are crazy to be doing this. I kind of left
it at that. And I came across a couple of
similar conflicts between what everybody in
corporate world believed and what all these
lessons out of academic finance and accounting
were. In other words, it was about stock options
accounting, which was a big, controversial
thing in the late '90s. Basically, all the
accountants thought it should be accounted
for as an expense. Everybody in Silicon Valley
said that would be a disaster because the
feeling was somehow it would cause all the
stock prices of Silicon Valley companies to
collapse. That was one--that was a bad reason,
the better reason why, it would just cause
executives to give out fewer of them. So,
I did a lot of that writing. I was sort of
puzzled by this lack of interest in the academe
in the thought that maybe markets weren't
always--be able to see through everything.
I went away. I went to London. I was Fortune's
Europe guy for a couple of years, came back
and was in the office in New York in 2002
and just happened to pick up this book by
a Caltech economist, specialized in finance,
where I just sort of leafing through, I realize
he was saying that actually he didn't believe
anymore that markets could see every--see
through everything and were perfectly efficient.
And very quickly, as I started looking through,
I realized right around when I'd written that
first article for Fortune in '97, there had
been this big shift in academic finance. There
were lots of people questioning whether something
like the tech stock bubble of 1999 and 2000
could be explained by anything other than
just people going a bit nuts. And that struck
me as a good idea for an article, wrote an
article for Fortune called--I think it was
called, "Is the Market Rational? No, But Neither
Are You, So Don't Think You Can Beat It."
It was a very investing focus because it was
a foreign investor guide. And then that led
to this book. Some guy from a publisher, Harper-Collins
came and said I should write a book about
that and nobody had ever--from a reputable
publisher had ever asked me to that before,
and, so, I said yes, which is something I
regretted greatly over many of the last five
or six years. But it's okay now. And what
I--so what I thought is I don't want to write
this polemic. I just want to the story of
why did all these accounting professors and
finance professors and a lot of economists
come to believe that financial markets, the
stock market in particular, were so smart
and able to see through everything and not
subject to bubbles and everything else. And
the story I came up with is it was this combination
of things. I mean, there are certain elements
that have been there in economics forever
because there are certain elements of truth
to it. Markets are smart. They react to things.
They can see through people's nonsense sometimes.
And the whole idea of Adam Smith's invisible
hand of market forces moving things in relatively
positive direction without--because of the
actions of lots of selfish people looking
out for themselves, that's been around forever,
but we've developed after World War II was
this combination of, first, it was the rise
of statistics and mathematical modeling, not
just in economics but all over the corporate
America and a lot of that, I mean, it was
partly because of advances in statistics.
A lot of it was just because World War II,
the experience. I mean, U.S. and U.K. used
statistical thinking in a way that the Axis
Powers did not. And it really helped. They
called this operations research. It was the
term [INDISTINCT] for what they were in general
doing. And a lot of economists were involved.
Milton Friedman spent part of World War II
helped--helping working at this statistics
office at Columbia University, helping figure
out things like how many pieces you want to
score in artillery shell into--so, to determine
whether it blows up into lots of little pieces
or just a few big ones. And it's a risk [INDISTINCT]
thing. If it's the big pieces, they cause
more damage if they hit. If it's the little
pieces, they are more likely to hit but they
cause less damage if they hit. And during--in
the middle of the Battle of the Bulge, they
were actually gunnery officers who flew back
to Washington to consult with Milton Friedman
about what to do, which obviously gave him
and other economist a certain confidence in
what they could do with these tools. So, there
was that. There was the collapse of what had
been for awhile there on the first part of
the century in the U.S., kind of the dominant
economic tradition, which was they called
themselves institutionalists, mostly. And,
really, the guy now who most of us remember
who was part of this tradition is John Kenneth
Galbraith, but it's sort of this historical,
literary way of looking at economics that's
very appealing to journalists like me, but
totally had no answers during the Great Depression.
And so people started looking to people like
John Maynard Keynes, who really was a more
conventional economist who was just willing
to have different ideas. And then the other
part of it was just sort of political waves.
There were these beginnings of a libertarian
backlash against the New Deal and Great Society
and all of these programs. And so these things
all came together at Chicago and at MIT. And
at MIT the focus was on statistics and the
math and this idea that randomness was this
really important concept to understanding
pretty much everything that goes on in the
world. And it is in so many things. And it
sort of came about as this way to tweak all
these people who thought you could stock charts
and divine truth out of the fact that over
the past 40 years, if you have like head and
shoulders is one thing, that that will lead
to some result afterwards. And what a lot
of statisticians and economists from the '30s
and to the '50s were able to show is you could
create all those same patterns with random
processes. So, there was that coming out of
MIT, which was basically market movements
are akin to random movements, they're really
to predict. I mean, maybe you can--maybe some
people can, but, in general, there's no easy
picking in the stock market. That came together
with Chicago where everybody agreed with that
but gave it this more ideological phrase where
it became this idea that, "Well, if markets
were perfectly, rationally reflecting all
available information that's out there, then
their movements would be random because they'd
just be reflecting--I mean, news is random,
so they would be reflecting changes in news,
changes in risk assessment to a certain extent,
but there would be no really to detect patterns
in them. So, the idea of a rational market
would be a random market. Market seemed to
be pretty random; therefore, markets must
be rational. And that led to this whole research
project at Chicago of finding evidence that
market, the stock market in particular, was
really doing a great job of assigning prices
to things. And in one line of research was
just looking at mutual fund performance and
finding that mutual funds as a group didn't
beat the market. And, now, that seems kind
of obvious because mutual funds are such a
big part of the market, and I think that was
part of the explanation for why they did it
in the '60s either. But the idea up to then,
the stock market investing was dominated by
individual investors so the [INDISTINCT] more
professionals are going to do better than
them. And here are a bunch of highly-paid
professionals as a group, especially when
you adjust for their volatility of their performance;
they didn't do any better than the market.
So that was one bit of evidence. Another bit
was that prices reacted really swiftly to
new information. Often, new information that
hadn't been publicly disclosed, markets could
sniff it out. And, again, these are all valid
points and--but it kind of came together into
this all-encompassing view of the world that,
basically--I mean, the simplest way to put
it is "the price is right." And there actually
was a professor at the University of Rochester,
which was sort of University of Chicago junior
in the 1970s, who would start his classes
by yelling, "The price is right! The price
is right!" So, that was the belief. And there
was this side element that seemed to come
attached to all of these, and it doesn't have
to be--and these don't have to go together,
but, I guess, because all these people were
saying that, "OK, markets are unpredictable.
We can't predict prices. Nobody can predict
prices," but they still want to give people
something useful. What they said is, "Well,
we can't predict price movements, but we can
say something about the riskiness of a particular
security." And, for the most part, they just
measured riskiness as volatility. I mean,
they came up with more convoluted ways. And
so coming out of this, here's this bunch of
people, young finance professors from Chicago
and MIT and increasingly elsewhere--Berkley,
Stanford, UCLA was a real hotbed as well--coming
along in the '70s who had this pretty clear
view of how the world worked. And it was one
in which there was no point in sneaking around
trying to figure out which particular stock
to buy and beat the market that way. There
was a lot of point in owning stocks because
over time I did lots of historical research
that had performed really well over time,
and there was an explanation for that. It
was because they were riskier over short periods
and, therefore, over time that should reward
you. And so that's my method of rational market.
That's--it probably--it peaked between about
the--in academia--between the late '60s and
early '80s. And what sort of impact did it
have? Well, the--I mean, some of the first
things that came from these people were all
these measurements of investing performance
that--like the sharp ratio, alpha, et cetera.
They're really big in the institutional investing
world, but they find their way into other
things like Morning Star ratings and stuff
like that. The second thing was index funds
which--I love index funds and I think they're
great things for lots of reasons, and you
don't have to believe markets are efficient
or rational to think an index fund is a good
idea, but I don't think index funds would
have happened in the '70s. The first one in
an institutional level was right around the
corner here at what was then Wells Fargo Global
Investors, it became Barclays Global Investors.
I don't know if it has become BlackRock Global
Investors now or what, but it's going to be
global investors. And then Vanguard--Jack
Vogel invented--well, created the first index
fund for retail investors a few years later.
Option pricing models and the rise of derivatives
markets, again, it could have happened without
this belief that prices are rational, but
it makes a lot more sense to believe in an
option pricing formula which is based on existing
prices of the underlying securities, if you
believe those existing prices mean something.
So, that was led to that. In the law, there
was huge transformation of thinking about
corporate information disclosure and lots
of other things because of this idea that
markets are really efficient. And then in
terms of deregulation, clearly, this thing
he played a role in it, but a lot of the financial
regulations that fell apart in the '70s just
fell apart because they weren't designed to
cope with inflation and you had things like
Reg. Q that said you could only pay whatever
was 5 percent on the savings account. It didn't
work very well when inflation was 10 percent.
So, I don't want to give too much credit to
this myth in all of the changes that happened,
but the thing that definitely did happen starting
in the '70s was this sort of "financialization
of American life" where financial markets
came to play a bigger role. People, instead
of having their money in a bank, they have
it in a market account. And then, increasingly,
instead of having money in a pension, they
had it in a Farrow and Kaye (ph) Mutual Funds.
And, again, this happened for lots of reasons
outside of what a bunch of professors at Chicago
said. But this whole idea that markets are
these great rational things made it a lot
more palatable, made this a popular thing.
Now, what's interesting is right about in
the early '80s, the first young professors
looking to raise some hell started raising
their hands, and Bob Sheller, who's now a
familiar face with his floppy hair on TV and
everywhere else, he's a Yale economist and
a prolific author--he wrote a paper that,
I think, was published in '81, and he was
sort of raising a hand, "Yes, but..." And
it was, gee, it looked like the movements
of stock prices were a whole lot more volatile
than any--and the particular thing he picked
was the dividends that were subsequently paid,
but lots of other people did research with
just about every other fundamental variable
you can come up with, and it was clear that
the market's movements were much more volatile.
And then another guy who is sort of prominent
these days, Larry Summers, who is a young
economist at Harvard--well, initially, MIT
then Harvard at that time. He did this paper
sort of showing that it was impossible to
tell a rationally unpredictable market from
an irrationally unpredictable market unless
you had, I think it was a 150 years of data.
And so it was just basically the point that,
you know, maybe the market is random, which
means prices are rational, but maybe not.
Nobody knows. And so as the years went by,
more and more of these ideas that everybody
was so sure about in the '50s and '60s got
taken apart in academic finance. But the interesting
thing that was going on in the wider world
is the 1990s were happening. And in sort of
the popular world, in the popular press, in
corporate America and everywhere else, markets
seemed to be working really well. And it wasn't
just the fall of the Berlin Wall and all of
that. It was that compared to what, say, the
German or Japanese economy, which were these
very bank-dominated, don't-rely-on-the-price-is-set
in financial markets to determine all that
much, they were struggling. The U.S. and the
U.K. were doing great. And so--and these fascinating
things happened. Like Larry Summers, who had
been this huge critic of financial markets
in the '80s was suddenly working first at
the World Bank, then at the Clinton administration,
basically saying, well, you know, they're
flawed but they work a whole lot better than
anything else. And I guess one way to look
at it is Milton Friedman talked about--he
had this famous line about monetary policy
like Fed decisions, they have effect on the
real economy with long and variable lags.
And I think the same--the same is true of
ideas, intellectual ideas that come out of
universities and elsewhere is they're starting
to have their impact on a popular culture
years after they did on campus. And I just--I
mean another classic thing in the '90s, is,
before the 1990s, if people were talking how
big a company was, it was always its revenue
or its profits. And those are both flawed
measures, all agree. But in the '90s, it switched
completely to you just talk about the market
gap and that tells you everything. And, again,
it is moral encompassing, but as we learned
at the end of the '90s, it can give you some
kind of weird measures of who is important
and who is not, so, which bring us all to
then to kind of "what went wrong?" And--I
mean, clearly the simplest thing of what went
wrong is lots of people were given mortgages
that there's no way they could have afford
to pay back unless housing prices kept rising.
And the sort of more complicated--I mean,
I was just trying to come up with the one--one
line explanation is that the markets for mortgage
securities failed to price--they failed the
price risk. And what it turned out to be,
and I think the problem that financial markets
have is they really did it differentiating
like the riskiness of the two different companies,
of comparing two different companies, even
different industries. What they're really
bad at is--and it's understandable--is gauging
the risk that they themselves create. And
I think that's what happened in the mortgage
market is that the increasingly lax lending
standards. I mean, obviously some of this
was brought on by regulatory decisions and
the sort of obsession in Washington with people
owning homes, but in the end they were for
the most part private investors around the
world buying these mortgage securities, and
they were buying them for way too cheap, given
how risky they were. And the thing about that
is that happens. It's happened again and again
throughout history, that these moments have
come when people decide to just utterly ignore
the potential riskiness of things and just
look only at potential returns. And so you
can't blame that on this myth of the rational
market. What you can say though is that regulators
and bankers and homebuyers and a lot of other
people were sort of singularly unprepared
for what happened because of the dominance
of this view of financial markets in which
things always happen. Prices always move for
a reason and price movements are commonly
rational enough to be accounted for in pretty
simple risk models. And that's kind of where
we are now. And I don't--again, this book
I've written is--it's a story about where
these ideas came from, where the challengers
came from, and the sort of muddle we're in
right now. I haven't written the answer, and
I don't think anybody has it at the moment.
One of the issues is just because markets
are flawed and have these bubbles and panics
and crashes, it doesn't mean that you're going
to come up with some government regulators
who do things better. And in fact one of the
problematic things I think about especially
banking regulation is there was this movement
over the past decade or two to have more flexible
banking regulation, give regulators more leeway
to do what they think, they thought was right,
but they caught up in all the same craziness
that markets do. So, the two things that keep
coming to mind is, one, this financial market
bubbles seem to cause a lot more damage when
they're built on debt rather than equity.
So you had the '90s tech stock bubble which--I
mean, it caused a lot of damage in the Bay
Area but it wasn't this economic disaster
because for the most part people were putting
up money that they had no contractual right
to get back. They were willing to take that
risk, whereas with the mortgages and housing,
it was much more debt-fueled bubble and, you
know, people have contracts. They're supposed
to get paid. Those break down, you start having
all these big troubles in the financial system.
So, clearly, some limitations of leverage
in boom times make sense. I don't know what
that limitation ought to be. And then--but
the other obvious thing is markets are these--financial
markets, in particular, are just spectacularly
efficient institution, but it's a really bad
idea to have a society that's entirely run
by them. And I'm not saying we did exactly,
but there were times in the late '90s when
it—-we seemed to be coming close. It's—-there
is a reason why we have these obviously less
efficient but at least different bodies from
charitable organizations to religious ones
to corporations themselves to governments.
Diversity brings better answers for the most
part, and I think diversity of sort of the
structure of economic institutions is part
of that. So that's where I am now in the story.
I would love to move it up to Q&A. Yep?
>> Okay. Sure. So just a question on indexing
and John Bogle. I mean, there's, you know,
a notion that for an individual price there's
some irrationality and all kinds of behavioral
things going on, but in aggregate, across
the market where you have indexing for the,
you know, basically, the entire marketplace,
what is your view in terms of the role of
rational decision-making or the fact that
you basically are able to max that or at least
obviate some of the behavioral consequences
by indexing?
>> FOX: Well, I love indexing but I--the mean
reason I loved it 'cause—-well, first of
all, because I've just realized over the past
10 or 15 years that, you know, part time,
I'm probably a bad investor period. I'm doing
it part time in the evenings, I'm just crapped
out. So I'm better off advocating some of
that, and just saying, "Okay, I don't think
the market is perfect, but I think it probably
knows better than me most of the time." But
the mean reason is that indexing is cheap,
and this sort of really basic equation that
it was espoused by people like Bill Sharpe
and Jack Bogle in the '60s and '70s, so there
are some identification with the efficient
market, rational market idea, but it doesn't
really have to go together. It's just that
investors, as a whole, are going to trail
the market by the amount of their costs, I
mean, because investors as a whole are the
market. Any sort of costs, that subtracts
from what you're going to make. So, if you're
an investor whose costs are lower than the
average costs, then you're doing better than
most people. I mean, you're already doing
better than most people regardless of anything
else. I mean, the issues with indexing—-I
mean, obviously, one issue would be if everybody
indexed, then prices will be totally crazy
because it would just, everybody it'd be—-and
to a certain extent, the actual efficiency
and rationality of markets is probably dependent
on how many people believe in their efficiency
and rationality because--and it is interesting
that a lot of these ideas came about after
this long period from the '30s through the
'60s where there weren't many people participating
in the stock market. Those who were participating
were, up until the early '60s, were very heavily
skewed towards value investors like Benjamin
Graham, and they were making prices steadily
more rational as that time went by. And if
you look back at the history of prices where,
you know, it just decided to stop about 1932,
it was this calm, steady, sensible movement.
But now I can't remember where I was going
about. Oh, well, I'll come up to—I'll come
up with the next question. Another question?
Yep?
>> [INDISTINCT] issues with the efficient
market theories, something that enabled the
crisis is, in America, people's comfort with
sort of living on debt and not saving enough.
And so I was wondering if you could give your
perspective on how that sort of came to be
in our culture and what enabled that, you
know, amongst like maybe mortgage securities
or whatever it was.
>> FOX: Well, I mean, I do think one reason
is sort of related to this efficient market
idea, which is that--and we've had since the
early--this kind of debt explosion, there've
been a steadily rising indebtedness from the
'30s, but you can just call that kind of a
correction of after people had totally freaked
out about debt in the Great Depression. But
starting in the early '80s, there was this
pretty dramatic rise in consumer indebtedness,
and it was clearly financed indirectly but
nonetheless really by the people from overseas--first,
Japan and, later, these broader group of countries.
And anytime there, you know, there have been
books and books written about all the horrible
indebtedness of America, and this is terrible,
and--I mean, two things would happen to discredit
those people. One, the debt levels kept rising
and we're okay, and the other was there was
an argument, well, who are you to say the
smarter than these financial markets which
decides it's okay to give all this people
this the [INDISTINCT]. So, that's part of
it. The other part, I mean, it's clearly there—-it's
cultural experience. I mean, Germany, because
of the more recent and more searing experience
it went through first with inflation in the
'20s and then with other economic collapse
after World War II, that seems to be a country
much less comfortable with debt than we are.
And I think, you know, something about the
whole American way of doing things. It's about
being hopeful and thinking things are going
to turn out better. So, we probably should
have hired [INDISTINCT] a lot of countries.
But I do think this idea that there's no—-you
can't have a wrong level of debt because this
is what the market decreed. I do think that
played at least a partial role in why no one
ever tried to do much about it. Yep?
>> Okay, since we're a technology company
and one that is obsessed with speed, I was
wondering if you could say anything about
high frequency trading and how that might
affect rational pricing.
>> FOX: Well, one of the interesting—-happily,
I wrote in my column this week about that,
so...
>> [INDISTINCT]
>> FOX: No, but I'm not totally, because I've
been reading the stories for several weeks
and just wondering what, what are these people
doing? One of the things, because, clearly,
if you see everything from this idea that
markets are generally efficient and if you
throw more resources at them, they're only
going to get more efficient. And that's what
the people who defend high frequency trading,
it's just creating more liquidity, it's lowering
cost for everybody else. It's all a good thing.
The one flipside of that, and the problem
is the people who are concerned about it really
can't bring much of anything but vague fears.
But there's clearly, when you introduce sort
of a new level of speed to the market and
especially if other parts aren't at that rate
yet, you end with these pretty bad dislocations
sometimes. I mean, 1987 crash was, among other
things, very much it seems to me this interaction
between this really fast Chicago futures markets
in S&P 500 Futures and the like and then still
totally manual New York Stock Exchange. And
so you had the futures prices adjusting really
fast and that suddenly sent all these floor
brokers in New York to sell stocks and unleash
this panic because they didn't go together.
So, there's some level—-some weird--I get
the concern that weird little thing happens
in the high frequency trading world could
suddenly cascade out into the rest of the
markets and nobody would know how to handle
it at first. Eventually, we figured it out
and it will be fine. The other thing is there'd
been--these guys at the—-it was initially
down at the Santa Fe Institute and now I think
the main guy who's doing it is Blake Lebaron
at Brandeis, they do this experimental security
markets on computers and create these agents
who have pretty simple beliefs about, you
know, they'll something simple like stock
prices are going to keep going up for awhile
and then if--and then they adjust their beliefs
reality hits them in the face. And one of
the really interesting things they've discovered
with these markets is if their agents are
sort of slow and take awhile to adjust their
beliefs to change market circumstances, you
get markets that look pretty much like those
out of financial theory. They're like rational
expectations market. But you start speeding
them up and having them change their minds
really quickly and interact with each other,
and you get more volatility and more fluctuation
and more bubbles. And I don't know, quite--so
there's some level at which—-at least in
financial markets, not necessarily in the
rest of life—-but in financial markets,
since everybody is sort of reacting, anticipating
what everybody else is doing, that extreme
speed might bring you less efficient, less
rational pricing. And I don't know the answer
to that, but I don't think it's a crazy fear.
I think that could be true. One of you guys
back there?
>> I have a question on your thought about
the "Wisdom of Crowds," which is a book that
gets a lot of credit at Google and in many
ways is built in to what we do, and so a book
called "The Myth of Rational Markets" could
be viewed as somewhat of an attack on the
"Wisdom of Crowds." And I'm just curious if
you've read "Wisdom of Crowds" or just how
you view that notion compared to what you've
written.
>> FOX: I love that book. And Surowiecki came
to my book party. But I think--I think it's
only wrong, I think that concept is wrong
to a certain extent in financial markets.
I think, if you're doing a prediction market
where there's something going to happen at
the end of that period, you don't have any
room for a bubble. People just make their
predictions and it's really--if you have a
diverse bunch of people making predictions,
you get a better result than you would if
you just asked one expert. So, in that sense,
the "Wisdom of Crowds" is absolutely right.
I think the issue with financial markets--and
it's kind of funny, it's all coming---I mean,
Keynes' has this famous chapter of his "General
Theory," which is this mostly unreadable book,
but chapter 12 is this depiction of financial
markets and he is just describing how hard
they are because basically you're anticipating
what other people are anticipating that other
people are going to do. And in the stock market,
I mean, at least in some--in futures and option
markets, there are expiration dates, so, at
a certain point, you come to, okay, it has
to be this. But in stock markets, I mean,
there are potential-—people can take a company
private or there can be a merger. There are
events that can happen that sort of--or a
company can liquidate that force the prices
to come in contact with reality, but over
really long periods of time, it could just
be different people's opinion interacting
with each other. And so, yeah, I think it's
a totally valid concept. I don't think it
applies in the same way to financial markets
because basically financial markets are prediction
markets about prediction about predictions,
and that's different from just a straight
prediction market.
>> So, let's assume that tomorrow, policymakers
come around to your view of things and assume
that markets are irrational. Well, what do
you think that should imply for the structure
of institutions either in terms of controlling
connectiveness or size or kind of just overall
risk levels and what we as a society should
do to hedge?
>> FOX: If I have the answer to that--well,
because obviously, I mean, one level within
the federal reserve system, there's this queer
thinking now that up until after Greens-...
a year or two after Greenspan left, the idea
was always "we know there are bubbles, we
are not trying to claim that markets are always
perfectly rational, but we can't identify
them ahead of time and so, we'll just clean
up afterwards." And that was sort of the Greenspan
ethos the whole time he was head of the Fed.
Now, you are hearing a lot of voices at the
Fed saying, well, actually we can identify
when debt levels are going up a lot and we
can do something about that. We don't necessarily
have to say that prices are wrong in the markets,
but there's something we can do sort of lean
against the wind in terms of the debt cycle.
Beyond--in terms of interconnectiveness of
institutions, I wonder about that because
lots of people think, oh, if only we just
had smaller financial institutions, this would
all be fine. I think some of what you've--what
we've seen about the way markets--financial
markets behave is you can have lots of smaller
institutions and they all lean in the same
direction and has the same impact as one big
institution going bust. So, I don't know that
that solves as many things as lot of people
think. And you look at the financial systems
that have survived this crisis best and I'm
sure in some cases is just the luck of who
is regulating them. But Canada has just this
clear case of a system that it's like five
big institutions all of which do everything--banking,
stock brokerage, investment banking--and they
came through the crisis brilliantly. It was
just there was more sense there of that idea
of keeping debt from getting out of hand.
There's one back here?
>> You mentioned value investing earlier,
and I've seen several interviews with Warren
Buffet where he talks about how he wants to
buy a company. He looks at the business. He
looks at the management, and he looks at the
numbers, and he looks at the stock price,
and if the market is undervalued and the company
[INDISTINCT] buys it. Is it really that easy?
Or are you saying that the numbers are irrational
and shouldn't be trusting him like that?
>> FOX: If--I mean, easy, I don't know, but
I think it's that simple in the sense that
that's one of the--I talked about Larry Summers
and Bob Schuler, but one of the other interesting
things that happened in the late '80s and
early '90s is this research by a lot of sort
of hardcore orthodox finance professors, including
Eugene Fama, the guy who authored the original
efficient market hypothesis, well, basically
showed that over time value stocks win, value
stocks outperform the market. And a lot of
the--this sort of orthodox finance crew has
struggled with that and the explanation Fama
gives is it's because somehow the value stocks
are riskier therefore they're going to do
better. I think, an equally good argument
is that value investing is riskier, especially
if you're a professional investor, because
if you're an agent for somebody else's money,
then exactly when should you be staying out
of stocks is when everybody wants to get into
stocks and exactly when you should be getting
in is when everybody wants to get out. And
the genius of Buffet is he set up his business
where he's not dependent on anybody else's
money. He just all these companies that have
nice cash flow and he has to invest that however
he wants. It doesn't matter what Richard Hathaway
stock price is. Everybody can abandoned him.
He still has the cash to invest whenever he
wants to. So, I think the big reason value
investing works is it's hard especially for
professionals. It's actually one of those
things that might be easier for individual
investors if they have the right mental framework
to be able to deal. Anything else? Yeah?
>> I spent a lot of times working with Wal-Mart
and their betting the farm on this newly frugal
customers, and their hypothesis goes something
like, you know, "we've hit a permanent reset
button, people will rethink value, will rethink
the shopping experience" and, certainly, they're
benefiting from that. They say things like
"on the other side of these recession, people
will have to rebuild their nest eggs," they,
you know, they'll have a changed mentality
for a long time. So, I'm just thinking, do
you believe that? There's a lot been written
about that. And if you do or don't, what does
that mean for the markets? And what does it
mean for stocks like Wal-Mart and others?
>> FOX: First of all, I do believe it. But
everybody was saying the same thing, although
probably to some lesser extent in the early
'90s. There was just a meeting the other day
at Time and someone was reminding us although
we had cover story and like 1991 or 1992 about
the new frugality, I think this was a bigger
crisis, people are in more financial trouble.
It's more likely to actually stick. And to
use a little Google Wisdom of Crowds, I watch
the little top 10 blog post on time.com all
the time, see how I'm doing, and there's this
brand new blogger we've got who we haven't
given any special publicity to or anything.
He's some guy living out in the woods in New
Hampshire, writes the cheapskate blog. And
it's like six out of the ten top posts are
invariably his posts, just saying, you know,
can you eat well on $50 a week, et cetera.
So, in terms of what that affects, I mean,
I think at one level, companies that cater
to that to a very value oriented audience
do better. At the other level, it just seems
to me that you're not going to have--you are
going to have this long period of indebtedness
either shrinking or not growing very much
at all. And if you look at over from early
1980s until now, or especially until like
five or ten years ago, a lot of the rise in
corporate profitability and in stock prices
had at least or partly be related to people
taking on more debt and spending more. And
so if that's not there, that's something that
weighs on financial markets overall I would
think. I mean, it's a healthy development,
but it means that you don't automatically
get a booming stock market out of it. Yep?
>> I was interested in your views on loss
aversion and how you think that skews individual
and institutional investment decisions?
>> FOX: That, I mean, interesting, when I
started writing this book, I thought it would
be this history of first the rise of this
hyper-rational view of markets and investing
and then its replacement by behavioral finance
and behavioral economics and all these ideas
like loss aversion that, basically, instead
of just sort of rationally looking at all
possibilities and weighing the risks, you
are much more concerned about going back from
your current state than weighing equally whether
you're back or forward. So, clearly, it affects
individual decision-making. And, I mean, at
the institutional level, I'm sure it's there.
I think there are so many other interesting
factors at the institutional level because
of the added complication of being an agent
and having customers that you are working
for. The thing that's difficult though is
finding ways that that's reflected in prices.
And that's been one of the really interesting
things that basically behavioral finance is
brought--given all these great answers about
how you could better structure a 401K program
or just how individuals should think about
investing. It hasn't really delivered much
of all on why prices do what they do and that
leads a lot the kind of old guard finance
people to say, oh, we won. And it's not only
that, it's just--we've got this model when
there's no perfect clear model that explains
everything. There are just different explanation
for different things. Anything else? Yep?
>> I was wondering if you had heard of the
Austrian Business Cycle Theory and how much
credence you put into it because a lot of
the stuff you've been talking about touches
on things that are kind of predicted by the
Austrian School.
>> FOX: Yeah, I mean, I gave some play to
some Austrians in the book and I thought at
times about going much more in-depth and,
you know, spending Vienna in the 1880s, the
rise of Austrian theories. And I didn't for
a couple of reasons--one was that just if
I'm looking at--it is basically a book about
mainstream thinking, academic thinking about
these ideas. And Austrian ideas, I mean, there
were moments like when Hayek wrote the Road
to Serfdom and his paper about information
and prices that they were very influential,
but on a whole, they haven't been. And I guess
the one other thing--and I don't think this
is like the actual Austrians from way back
when, but a lot of the people who call themselves
Austrian Business Cycle theorists now, it's
strikes me as this very simplistic view of
the world where everything is the federal
reserves' fault. And my problem with that
is we had financial crisis in booms and busts
before we have a federal reserve, so, it just--and
we actually created the Fed because we thought
it would get us out of them. And, clearly,
it hasn't, although, they've been less frequent.
So, I don't know if it's--you could argue
that that's a problem because if you don't
have them frequently, people don't learn how
to deal with them and you end with really
big crises like this or the great depression,
where if you just let it happen every 10 years,
you'd less of a problem. So, I don't--I mean,
I'm fascinated with those discussions, those
arguments, it's something in the end I decided
I would have to add another 200 pages to my
book but I didn't have time for so I didn't,
but maybe some other time.
>> Well, thank you very much Justin.
>> FOX: Thank you. This is fun.